is on the a line drop it two squares
down
horizontal action i think you can do it
immediately ivanka you can do it
you don't even need to allow nike i like
your idea but just line up those two
rooks on the first row okay he's done it
okay so the reason why i wanted to push
my pawn forward because i was
well i was thinking that maybe the
knight can come and defend and i don't
want to allow that
but the night okay that's the only move
the knight must come to defend the
bishop if white's bishop moves right now
the black rooks will swing across and
checkmate the white king
you cannot uh evacuate that first row
you have to keep those blacks rooks from
getting to that white king but white's
king stepping back
now white's bishop is paralyzed it's
pinned white's rook is paralyzed
defending it
and now okay it's it's going to be game
overs now
liam just brings his knight in to secure
that bishop's fate and he ends the game
with a night fork attacking the white
king attacking the white rook
liam wins and he celebrates liam quang
is ready for the semi-finals the first
time
he reaches